hey guys Dave I hope you know who's who
at this point they probably I'm Anna
that's Dave here we go so I saw this
interesting article the 10 biggest
cities in the United States I think it
was a Gallup poll so I'm just gonna read
him 10 to 1 10 being the 10 yes Lincoln
Nebraska San Francisco California San
Luis Obispo California Naples Florida
and Arbor Michigan San Jose California
Honolulu Hawaii Fort Collins Colorado
number two Boulder Colorado there's two
Colorado's right there that might have
something to do with the week
and number one Los Angeles sorry sister
it is Provo Utah Utah yeah really
very confusing but I'm not Utah before
we get to Utah back you know I thought
this would be interesting way to just
talk about sort of like what makes us
happy you know obviously a lot of this
has to do with whether I swim Honolulu
that's got to be weather-related people
that you're around the types of jobs you
know like New York and Los Angeles where
everyone you know those who seem to be
like the go-getter cities right not on
the list
that's insane well I think it's because
in New York in LA you're constantly
stressed out about making money the cost
of living is way too high the rent is
too damn high
so I think that's part of the problem
but I have to say la is the place for me
because I love that I thrive in that
kind of environment where there's
competition and you know the there are
endless possibilities for your career
sometimes I get a little jealous about
how Europeans live their lives because
they work to live not live to work yeah
and for me it's the other way around
um you want the siesta I sometimes want
to see esta but I love feeling like yeah
I'm working hard there's a goal there's
a purpose like that's what really makes
me happy but another thing that makes me
happy is a good food good weather hot
men Latin men like you're not gonna find
Latin men in your I know an elegant
comparative way to Europe like I'm not
even good old Provo and bold
la or Europe well there's Spain so I'm
aware of Spain okay yeah and she's going
to Spain by the way what a month it
happens oh yeah
watch out yeah well the New York thing
you know I grew up in the suburbs of New
York City and lived in New York City
basically the last like 14 years until I
moved to LA a year ago and there's
actually no comparison between the new
artists there's so much of everything
constantly that you almost don't realize
it when you're there the constant like
hustle and bustle and the buzzing and
like everyone's sort of miserable and
angry but then when you get to actually
talk to people they're actually quite
friendly that's the secret of New York
yeah nobody wants to know people are
always happy to give you directions
usually they said yeah but no they'll at
least you know they'll get you somewhere
but LA to me after living in New York
like this is the most laid-back place on
earth I know that's not actually but I
know that's not actually true crew
relative to me perhaps Honolulu or many
other place yeah but for me this is the
perfect blend of like lifestyle and that
work is always happening here and it's
beautiful words you probably hear in the
birds eating yes well I think that New
York is a completely different animal
there's no place like New York so la is
definitely laid-back in comparison but I
think that la is a perfect mix between
laid-back and hard-working laid-back and
crazy and I love the city I can't
imagine living anywhere else to be
honest with you know we're clearly sure
I can be departing I've been to Portland
yet and I really really want to go there
but we should talk about some of these
other things we're showing our New York
and LA bias here so Provo Utah what the
hell could be going on I have to be
honest with you excuse my ignorance I've
never it is a place it is a place I
don't know if you're from Provo Utah
please let us know they're Honolulu that
one seems pretty obvious yeah then you
got like San Jose and San Luis Obispo at
your California things that make sense
Naples Florida also nice there Lincoln
Nebraska have not been to Lincoln
number or greater Nebraska hasn't been
there either san francisco's number nine
which i think is kinda interesting
because everyone says it's a great city
and I've been there and it really is
fantastic but easy it is very expensive
I love San Francisco the last time I
went there was with my friend Lauren and
we had so much fun we didn't rent a car
we just like walked around and we walked
throughout the entire city yeah it was
so great and so many cool little areas
the Mission District is my favorite they
have some bakeries like Mexican bakeries
that are to die for to die to die anyway
we're really curious what do you guys
think where do you guys live what makes
you want to live there there's weather
over I job that's having family clothes
override something else already they
have to get away from your family
whatever it is let us know comments
write down below and we may think trip
to Provo and find out what you crazy
kids